MATT GAETZ: Dr. Kahl, do we have
DOD personnel in Ukraine now?
COLIN KAHL: We do.
We have a couple
dozen at the embassy.
MATT GAETZ: Other than the
embassy, any other personnel?
COLIN KAHL: Nope.
MATT GAETZ: How about CIA?
Are they training
folks in Ukraine?
COLIN KAHL: I'm not
going to talk about that
in an unclassified setting.
Happy to talk about that further
in the classified briefing.
MATT GAETZ: Is
the Azov Battalion
getting access to US weapons?
COLIN KAHL: Not
that I'm aware of.
But if you have information--
MATT GAETZ: I
[INAUDIBLE] consent
to enter into the
record the Global
Times investigative report
that talks about training.
It's from the Atlantic Council's
Digital Forensics Research Lab
citing the Azov Battalion
was even getting
stuff as far back as 2018.
- Without objection, so ordered.
MATT GAETZ: Any
reason to disagree
with that assessment, Dr. Kahl?
COLIN KAHL: Is this the--
I'm sorry.
Is this the Global
Times from China?
MATT GAETZ: No, this is--
well--
COLIN KAHL: That's
what you read.
MATT GAETZ: Yeah, it might be.
Yeah, would that be a reason--
MATT GAETZ: I, as
a general matter,
I don't take Beijing's
propaganda at face value.
MATT GAETZ: Well, no, no.
But just tell me if the
allegation is true or false.
I mean--
COLIN KAHL: I don't have any
evidence one way or the other.
As a general matter, I don't
take Beijing's propaganda
at face value.
MATT GAETZ: Fair enough.
I would agree with
that assessment.